Okay.
Schönen guten Abend.
Ogu-San ist mein Name.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzstätig
und möchte gerne das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Ich werde Ihnen erst ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen
und dann zu Ihrem Beschwerden übergehen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, ja.
Super.
Wie heißen Sie das?
Ich heiße Maximilian Habeck.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen, Namen, Buchstabieren?
Ja, der Vorname Maximilian M-A-X-I-M-I-L-I-A-N.
Maximilian.
Ja, Maximilian.
Habeck, Habeck, H-A-B-E-C-K.
Ja, super.
Herr Habeck, okay.
Wie heißen Sie Herr Habeck?
Ich bin 23.
23.
Wann genau sind Sie geworden?
Am 15. November 2001.
2001.
Können Sie mir sagen, wie viel wiegen Sie?
Zur Zeit wiege ich 68 Kilo.
68.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,2 Meter.
Wo wohnen Sie Herr Habeck?
Ich wohne in Münster.
Münster.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarztin oder Ihr Hausarzt?
Auch Dr. Menke.
Menke.
Mit E.
M-I-N-K-I.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich studiere.
Welche Abteilung oder welche Studierung?
Ich studiere Jura.
Jura.
Darf ich Sie fragen, ob Sie verheiratet sind?
Nein, ich bin ledig.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Wunderbar, danke schön.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Was für zu uns?
Ich fühle mich in den letzten 3 Wochen ziemlich stark erschöpft.
Ich bin oft müde.
Ich habe wenig Appetit.
Ich bekomme auch relativ schnell Luftnot.
Ich treibe sonst viel Sport.
Aber joggen kann ich zurzeit gar nicht.
Das schaffe ich nicht.
Da bin ich zu schlapp, zu müde.
Ich habe stark weiße Fälle.
Besonders nachts muss ich stark schwitzen.
Dann habe ich jetzt Fieber gemessen.
Ich habe Fieber 8 und 3.
Ich habe Fieber 38,5.
Es geht mir nicht gut.
Können Sie mir sagen, dass Sie ähnliche Beschwerden schon einmal hätten?
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Haben Sie bemerkt, ob es bestimmte Auslöse für die Beschwerden gibt?
Nein, aber ich habe keine Erklärung dafür.
Letzter 3 war.
Okay.
Ich habe noch keine Erklärung dafür.
Ich habe bis heute die Beinstelle der Beschwerden.
Die sind nicht gut.
Ich habe die Le emergency.
Ich habe gewisse Muskelschmerzen.
Ich habe einen Maraton gelaufen.
Ich hatte auch Muskelschmerzen.
Ich hatte auch die Nenumriesen.
Das fühlt sich an.
Auch die Knochen, wie du sie tun.
habe keine Kopfschmerzen und Kopfschmerzen habe ich nicht. Ich habe noch so bemerkt irgendwie im Bauch
habe ich so ein Druckgefühl im linken Bauch unter den Rippen, an dem Rippenbogen. Da ist so ein
Druckgefühl, da muss ich immer hin fühlen, aber ich kann nichts fühlen, so tasten kann ich nicht.
Dann habe ich so den Eindruck, dass mein Hals etwas dicker ist, weil ein Hals ist geschwollen
auf der Seite, ja, es ist nicht gut.
Wo sind sie, wo sind sie Druckgefühle im Bauch?
Linken, Linken, Linken, ja, und Rippenbogen.
Ja, ja, da so in der Gegend.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Nein, Übelkeit, Erbrechen habe ich nicht, aber wenig Appetit.
Ich kann nicht gut essen. Ich muss mich zum Essen immer zwingen.
Haben Sie Schwindelgefühl?
Nein, nein.
Haben Sie noch weitere Beschwerden?
Nein, Luftnot habe ich, ich habe diese Nachtschweißstark, Knochenschmerzen, Muskelschmerzen, Druckgefühl im Bauch,
das Fieber, Müdigkeit.
Ich fasse das noch einmal zusammen, bitte kollegen Sie mich, falls ich etwas falsch notiert habe.
Sie haben seit letzten drei Wochen bestehende Stärker, Erschöpfung und Müdigkeit und Luftnot.
Sie haben wenig Appetit und sie haben nach Schweiß und Fieber.
Die Fieber ist 38,5 Stg und sie klagten über Druckgefühl in linken Oberwach.
Und mein Hals geschohlen?
Ja, so dicker, der Seite besonders, so hier.
Haben Sie Halsschmerzen?
Nein, Halsschmerzen habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Die Luftnot habe ich aber nicht in Ruhe, sondern ich wohne im zweiten Stockwerk.
Wenn ich die Treppen steige, da muss ich jetzt eine Pause machen, weil ich keine richtige Luft kriege.
Dann kann ich jetzt wieder weiter Treppen steigen.
Dritte Stock?
Zweite Stock.
Haben Sie Beinschmeißen oder Beinen?
Also allgemeine Muskelschmerzen.
Aber besonders habe ich nicht.
Leider sind Koronationerkrankungen von denen ich fließen sollte?
Also ich habe seit der Kindheit, habe ich Asthma.
Ich bin allergisch auf viele Pollen, aber auch auf Hausstaub.
Wir haben schon viel probiert, aber ich habe immer wieder Beschwerden.
Ich brauche dafür, dass ich dafür einen Spray nehme.
Dann habe ich noch ein chronisches Hautexem, besonders in der Ellenbäuger, hier am Ellenbogen und in der Kniekehle.
Das ist im Winter oft schlimmer, im Sommer ist es besser, wenn Sonne dran kommt.
Wie über der Espray handelt gegen Asthma?
Asthma nehme ich Spray ein, wie Arnie heißt es?
Könnten Sie bitte?
V-A-N-I, Fianie.
Das nehme ich zweimal pro Tag.
Und bei Bedarf, sonst wenn ich Sport treibe, was ich in den letzten drei Wochen nicht gemacht habe, weil ich zu müde bin,
sonst nehme ich vor dem Sport noch Salvutamol.
Wie ist die Dosierung?
Zweimal pro Tag.
Morgens ein und abends eine.
Das ist eine Kapsel, die wir in der Brat, und dann muss ich das einatmen.
Das ist so ein Staub, ein Pulver.
Sie haben gesagt, andere Medikamente.
Bei Bedarf nehme ich vor dem Sport Salvutamol.
Leiden Sie andere krönchen Erkrankungen?
Nein, einmal Asthma und einmal Polynamen.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, als Kind, da war ich, glaube ich, zehn Jahre alt, da hatte ich eine Mandeloperation.
Und vor zwei Jahren wurde am linken Knie, der Meniscus,
vor zwei Jahren wurde am linken Knie der Meniscus operiert mit einer Knie-Spiegelung.
Da wurde der Meniscus wieder genäht, der war eingerissen,
das ist wahrscheinlich beim Fußballspielen passiert.
Aber danach ist es gut gegangen, habe ich keine Probleme mehr gehabt.
Jetzt möchte ich Sie nach Krankheiten in Ihrer Familie fragen.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, der Vater ist 52 Jahre alt.
Er hatte in den letzten Jahren immer wieder Probleme mit geschwüren Amts-12-Fingerdamm.
Da muss er jetzt regelmäßig Tabletten nehmen und es ist jetzt besser geworden.
Er hatte auch hohen Blutdruck seit einigen Jahren.
Da muss er auch Medikamente nehmen, aber ich weiß nicht, welche.
Dann hatte er vor zwei Jahren nach einer Covid-Infektion eine Herzmuskelentzündung.
Das war es, oder?
Bei Vater war es, dass die Mutter die ist, 151 Jahre alt, die hat auch Asthma, so wie ich.
Hast du mal?
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, eine Schwester, die ist 24 Jahre alt, die ist gesund.
Je weiter geht es mit der Vegetativeranmese.
Sie haben gesagt, ich habe Fieber und leiden Sie dann Schweißarsprüchen.
Ja, ich habe starken Nachts besonders.
Ich schwitze sehr stark.
Ich muss in der Nacht immer ein neues T-Shirt anziehen, weil das so durchgeschwitzt ist.
Und schlafen sehr gut?
Nein, seitdem ich jetzt seit drei Wochen, seitdem es mir nicht so gut geht, schlafe ich auch nicht so gut.
Weil ich tagsüber immer etwas müde bin, dann schlafe ich tagsüber etwas und da ist der Nachtschlaf jetzt zur Zeit nicht gut.
Haben Sie Husten?
Durch das Asthma habe ich manchmal Husten, aber nicht stärker als sonst.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass in letzter Zeit ungewollt ab oder zu kommen?
Ja, das ist ein großes Problem.
Ich habe so schon vorher, bevor es mir jetzt so schlecht ging, habe ich bemerkt, so seit zwei Monaten habe ich Gewicht abgenommen, fast 8 Kilo.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen und mit dem Stullgang?
Nein, das ist alles in Ordnung.
Da habe ich keine Probleme.
Haben Sie Verstopfung oder Durchfall?
Nein, nein.
Können Sie mir sagen, ob Sie in Ihrem Privatleben oder Arbeitsleben Stress oder Angst haben?
Nein, das Studium ist zwar anstrengend, das ist ein gewisser Stress, aber ich fühle mich da jetzt nicht sehr stark beeinträchtigt.
Mehr Stress macht mir jetzt im Augenblick meinen Gesundheitszustand, falls es mir nicht gut geht.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie nehmen ein Zwei-Bit Tomaten und Ferne.
Ja.
Und nehmen Sie regelmäßig andere Medikamente ein?
Nein, nein.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie rauchen.
Nein, ich rauche nicht, auch wegen dem Ast war ich nicht.
Ich mache ja viel Sport, also rauchen tu ich nicht.
Super.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Nicht regelmäßig, aber am Wochenende mal auf einer Feier oder Party, da trinke ich auch mal eine Flasche Bier.
Sagen wir mal maximal zwei Flaschen Bier pro Woche.
Aber in den letzten drei Wochen glaube ich, seitdem es mir nicht gut geht, habe ich keinen Alkohol getrunken.
Ja, super.
Diese Frage ist rein routinmäßig. Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Wie ist das mit den Medikamenten?
Ist mir nicht bekannt.
Nein, ich habe es hier auch nicht.
Ja, Polen, früher und Hausstaubmilbe.
Hausstaub.
Wie ist das mit den Alergen?
Luftnot.
Man sagt, das Asthma kommt von den Polen, besonders früher, aber Hausstaub eben das ganze Jahr.
Das Problem ist Hausstaub.
Ist Ihre Impfstatus vollständig, zum Beispiel Kinderheit oder Covid-19?
Ich glaube, ich bin zurzeit gut geimpft, ausreichend geimpft.
Ja, das glaube ich.
Mein Impfspass jetzt nicht mit, den kann ich aber besorgen, kann ich Ihnen dann zeigen.
Ja, super.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland gereist?
Ja, ich war vor ungefähr drei Monaten.
Gut, vor drei Monaten war ich in Thailand und in Vietnam.
Zu einer so einer Backpacking-Tour mit Rucksack und da war ich gut drei Wochen unterwegs.
Haben Sie Ihre Reisen ein Problem oder eine Beschwerden?
Nein, ich hatte mal ein Tag oder zwei Tage etwas durchfragen und erbrechen in Thailand,
aber das war dann schnell wieder besser.
Sonst war da keine Komplikation in der Reise.
Ja, super.
Das war es, glaube ich.
Haben Sie noch Fragen oder wichtige Informationen für mich?
Ja, ich frage mich natürlich, was kann ich haben,
weil so etwas habe ich ja noch nie gehabt und so, dass es mir so lange schon so schlecht geht.
Ja, ich verstehe Ihnen.
Wir sind schon erledigt.
Ich habe eine Erleichterung geplant.
Ich habe jetzt auch eine Erleichterung geplant.
Ich habe nach einer Ausland gereicht.
Was heißt Tokax?
Was heißt Torax?
Röntgenbrust in den Brustbereich.
Brustkorb.
Ja, Brustkorb.
Gut.
Sobald alle Befunde vorliegen, können wir über die Diagnose und die Behandlung sprechen.
Okay, gut, das können wir so machen.
Danke.
Super.
Gut, dann haben Sie jetzt, sagen wir mal, 10 Minuten Zeit, sich einfach vorzubereiten.
Ich habe Sie an die Übersetzung der Patientensprache in die möglichst in die Fachbegriffe.
Und heute sind ja auch viele Kolleginnen und Kollegen zugeschaltet.
Vielleicht gibt es noch Fragen, die wir jetzt dann, die ich gerne beantworten.
Ja.
Die meisten Fragen sind, glaube ich, alle gut gestellt worden.
Es verbleiben, glaube ich, nicht mehr so viele Fragen.
Was könnte man denn noch fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja.
Haben Sie Engelgefühl, Brustschmerzen, Herzrasen oder Herzklopfen bemerkt?
Also Engelgefühl und Brustschmerzen habe ich nicht, aber ich habe bemerkt, dass mein Puls etwas schneller schlägt.
Vielleicht hängt das damit zusammen, weil ich so schnell erschöpft bin.
Normalerweise habe ich einen Puls von unter 60, Ruhepuls und den habe ich jetzt gemessen und der ist zurzeit so bei 80, 85.
Das kann ich gut vergleichen, weil ich das früher immer kontrolliert habe.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Sie belasse Haut bemerkt bei Ihnen?
Meine Freundin ist aufgefallen, dass ich so blass bin in letzter Zeit.
Sie wundert sich ja auch, dass ich so oft so müde bin und so viel schwitze.
Sie sagt auch, ich wäre blasser als sonst.
Anfang war das vielleicht nicht so, weil ich ja noch in Thailand war und wie Vietnam.
Da war ich dann relativ braun.
Da war viel Sonne.
Aber jetzt in letzter Zeit ist meine Freundin das aufgefallen.
Haben Sie schon einmal Käse aus Rohmilch gegessen?
Können Sie das bitte noch einmal wiederholen?
Käse aus Rohmilch?
Ja.
Das weiß ich gar nicht.
Ich habe gehört, das kann auch Krankheiten übertragen.
Aber das weiß ich jetzt gar nicht genau.
Kann ich Ihnen nichts sagen?
Hallo?
Ich habe etwas nur gehört, aber nicht richtig.
Können Sie das bitte wiederholen?
Nein.
Vielleicht kann man noch eine Frage stellen im Rahmen der Thailand-Reise
und Vietnam-Reise.
Ich habe extra das mit dem Impfen bewusst nicht gesagt.
Ich war vorher beim Open-Mediziner und habe alle Impfungen dort erhalten,
die notwendig waren für diese Reise und habe auch eine Malaria-Profilaxe gemacht.
Mit Tabletten.
Diese Frage sollte möglichst auch im Rahmen dieser Reise an am Nese,
wenn ich in Thailand war, sollte die auch gestellt werden.
Möglichst haben Sie eine Malaria-Profilaxe gemacht.
Gut.
Gibt es sonst noch Fragen?
Wenig Fragen.
Es ist ein gutes Zeichen, dass der Kollege alle entscheidenden Fragen eigentlich gestellt hat.
Das ist schon mal sehr positiv.
Schönen guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patientin vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, habe ich.
Herr Maximilian Habeck, 3-und 20-Jährige.
Er ist 28 kg.
68 kg.
Er ist 182 cm groß.
Herr Habeck ist Jurastudentin.
Okay.
Und ledig.
Ihre Hausarzt heißt Frau Dr. Menke.
Herr Habeck, ich stande heute wegen seit den letzten 3 Wochen bestehende Fatigue
und Fatigue in Möglichkeit, Appetitlosigkeit und Taschknö.
Ja, in Appetenz vielleicht?
Ja, in Appetenz.
Taschknö und Hypathidrose bei uns vor.
Die Dispnö ist eher ein Belastungsdispnö.
Also keine Ruhedispnö.
Das wäre eine Orthopnö, aber er hat eine Belastungsdispnö.
Er hat eine Belastungsdispnö.
Ja, bei einem Treppensteigen zum Beispiel.
Er leidet Fieber von 38,5 Stg.
Wissen Sie, wo er das gemessen hat?
Ja, ich habe nicht gefragt.
Er hat das im Mund gemessen.
Am besten immer Fragen, wo haben Sie das gemessen?
Gut.
Und begleitend sind, mir nach Marathon zu laufen.
Ja, also wie?
Er hat das verglichen.
Er hat Schmerzen wie nach einem Marathon.
Er ist jetzt ja kein Marathon gelaufen.
Das kann er nicht, weil er so schlapp ist.
Er beschreibt, nach einem Marathon habe ich solche Schmerzen gehabt.
So ähnliche Schmerzen.
Muskelschmerzen, Muskelkater sagen wir, Muskelkater.
Aber jetzt ist er nicht Marathon gelaufen.
Er hat nur einen Vergleich gemacht.
Er hat Müll und Atralgien.
Das ist auch eine Beschwerde.
Und außer dem klackte er über Druckgefühl im Hipokon-Rühm.
Im linken Hipokon-Rühm.
Und Hans geschuldene.
Er berichtet über eine Servikale Schwellung.
Oder ein Servikales Druckgefühl.
Er weiß nicht genau, er sagt, das fühlt sich dicker an.
Servikal.
Er berichtete, dass sie 3 zweite Stücke treppenlaufen.
Und er hat Atmung.
Sie haben vorhin ja schon gesagt, Belastungs-Display.
Belastungs-Luftnot.
Das reicht, glaube ich.
Das müssen Sie nicht nochmal über.
Er berichtet über Belastungs-Display beim Treppensteigen.
Das reicht.
Mehr muss man, glaube ich, nicht sagen.
Nicht entscheidend, ob es 2 Stockwerke sind oder 1.
Beim Treppensteigen.
Das ist ja ungewöhnlich für einen sonst gesunden Menschen.
Der Fitt ist.
Bekannte Krankungen, sei Asthma und Polenallergie.
Und Haustenallergie.
Sagen Sie ruhig, es besteht seit der Kindheit ein Asthma-Bronchale.
Man kann auch sagen ein allergisches Asthma-Bronchale auf Ausstaubmilbe und Polen.
Dann haben Sie das alles in einem Satz.
Ja.
Und an der Vorerkrankungen sei der Mathit auf Ellenbogen und auf.
Ich zeige es Ihnen mal.
Der Patient sagt in der Ellenbeuge und in der Kniekähle.
Kennen Sie die Begriffe?
Kubital.
Und Patella.
Nein, in der Kniekähle.
Hinten ist nicht die Patella.
Hinten ist die Pop-Litea.
Also Kubital und Pop-Litea ein Exem.
Was ja Asthmatica oft haben.
Ein ektopisches Exem oder Neurodermitis.
Der Mathit, oder?
Ja, der Mathitis ist ein bisschen noch ein anderer Begriff.
Ich würde eher sagen ein Exem und Kubital und Pop-Litea.
Ja, in der Lokalisation.
Ja.
Bekannte Veroperation.
Für die Verwaltungen.
Ich würde sagen, für die Verwaltungen,
für die Patienten.
Bei den Patienten.
Die Patienten.
Der Patient hat gesagt, es wurde der Meniscus operiert.
Meniscus.
Er wurde operiert.
Und die Operationstechnik war eine Spiegelung.
Spiegelung.
Genäht.
Atroskopie.
Atroskopie des linken Knies.
Dabei wurde eine Meniscus,
wahrscheinlich eine Meniscus Teilresekktion, durchgeführt.
Im Meniscus wird ja nicht mehr ganz entfernt,
sondern nur noch teilweise oder genäht.
Das macht man inzwischen nur noch sehr schonend.
Also vor zwei Jahren fand einer
Skopische meniscus OP, mehr wissen wir nicht am linken Knieschrad.
Also wir haben zwei Operationen.
Ja, und Tonselektomie im 10 Jahre.
Mit 10 Jahren, im Alter von 10 Jahren.
Nehmt der Patient Medikamente ein?
Die Patienten nehmen regelmäßig wie Annie.
Wie Annie, ja.
Zweimal pro Tag.
Ja.
Und Salgo Tamol bei Bedarf.
Gut.
Alles, ne?
Ja, alles.
Und die Familienanalyse, seit sich, beim Vater,
do denitis.
Wie alt ist der Vater?
Ihr Vater.
Sein Vater, sein, sein, ist Maskulinum, Maskulin, sein Vater.
Sein Vater sei 52 Jahre alt.
Ja.
Beim Vater, sein Vater leidet do denitis.
Ja, do denitis ist eine, eher so eine allgemeine,
vielleicht Schleimhautentzündung, aber der Patient hat 12 Finger.
Geschwürre, Geschwür.
Wie kennt ihr den Fachbegriff für Geschwürre?
Geschwürre.
Ulkus.
Ulkus, genau.
Wie heißt der Begriff? Ulkus?
Duodene.
Ja, duodene.
Der Vater leidet wohl an rezilivierenden Ulzeradudene.
Ja?
Ja.
Was hat der Vater noch an Erkrankungen?
Arbaterielle Hepartonie.
Ja.
Wo es zwei Jahre wegen Covid-19 meokardiert.
Ja, vor zwei Jahren hatte der Vater eine myocarditis,
wahrscheinlich nach einer Covid-19 Erkrankung, wahrscheinlich.
Was?
Der zeitliche Zusammenhang, weiß ich nicht, hat der Patient so berichtet.
Und die Mutter?
Ihre Mutter sei ...
Seine Mutter, seine Mutter, seine Mutter, seine Mutter,
sei 51 Jahre alt.
Ja.
Und leider an Asthma.
Sag mal, sagen Sie ruhig, Asthma-Bronchale.
Ja.
Auch an Asthma-Bronchale, so wie der Patient auch.
Das Geschwister.
Und Geschwister sei gesund.
Ja, okay.
Gut.
Und vegetative Annamnese.
Er war unauffällig bis auf Insomnia.
Ja.
Und er habe vor zwei Monaten ein, vor zwei Monaten,
acht Kilogramm abgenommen.
Seit zwei Monaten.
Also in den letzten zwei Monaten.
Seit zwei Monaten umgewollt, acht Kilogramm aufgenommen.
Ja.
Er habe ein Noir-Studium-Stress, oder?
Also ich würde sagen, besondere Stressfaktoren
werden liegen nicht vor.
Ja, also er sagte, das Studium ist zwar anstrengend,
aber es ist nicht so, dass er jetzt da ein Riesenproblem hat.
Sie müssten, wichtig ist, dass sie die Gewichtsabnahme
berichtig betonen, nicht so in einem Beisatz sagen.
Sie sagen sie ruhig, auffällig ist eine ungewollte Gewichtsabnahme
von ungefähr acht Kilogramm innerhalb der letzten zwei Monate.
Das ist schon ein auffälliger Befund.
Der sollte wirklich, dass der Oberarzt den auch hört.
Ja.
Und nicht dabei irgendwo, ja, das nicht mitbekommt.
Das ist eine wichtige Hinweis.
Gut.
Was gibt es sonst noch in der vegetativen Anamnese
oder bei den Risikofaktoren, Genussmittel?
Ja, sie rauchen nicht.
Und er trinke am Wochenende ein Kulaspier.
Ja, okay.
Und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Ja.
Und sein Impfstatus ist vollständig.
Sei vollständig.
Ja.
Und er sei vor drei Monaten in Thailand und Vietnam gereist.
Geh es ja gereist.
Wie lange war er dort?
Wissen Sie, wie lange die Reise dauerte?
Wie viele Tage?
Wie viele Wochen?
Drei Wochen.
Ja.
Ja, er ist dort gereist, gab es darauf?
Wir haben vorher Malaria pro flex gemacht.
Ja, okay.
Das war es.
Okay.
Also wichtig sind diese Angaben, wie die Gewichtsabnahme,
wie die Reise, die zurückliegende Reise sollten wirklich klar betont werden.
Auch gegenüber dem Oberarzt, dass das und die Gewichtsabnahme.
Okay.
Ich fange mal kurz zusammen, was mir jetzt hängen geblieben ist.
Der Patient, Herr Haabek, ist 23 Jahre alt.
Er ist 182 groß und wiegt zur Zeit 68 Kilogramm.
Herr Haabek fühlt sich seit ungefähr drei Wochen sehr erschöpft, müde.
Er hat ein Fatigue-Syndrom.
Er hat febrile Temperaturen 38,5.
Er hat ausgeprägte Hyperhydrosis, besonders in der Nacht.
Er hat eine Belastungs-Dispnö.
Er hat Möalviren, auch vielleicht Atralviren.
Er klagt über ein Druckgefühl im linken Hypochondrium
und über unklare zervikale Schwellungen.
Erwähnenswert ist, dass er eine Gewichtsabnahme von ungefähr 8 Kilogramm
in den letzten zwei Monaten bemerkt hat.
Er war vor drei Monaten für die Dauer von drei Wochen
in Vietnam und in Thailand.
Er war vorher beim Tropenmediziner
und hat sich alle nötigen Impfungen geben lassen.
Er hat auch eine Malaria-Profilaxe betrieben.
Ja.
An chronischen Erkrankungen hat er seit der Kindheit
ein allergisches Asthma-Brontiale auf Hausstorb, Milbe und Pollen.
Er hat ein chronisches Exem,
besonders in Kubital und Popliteal.
Er ist mit zehn Jahren Ton selekturiert worden.
Er hatte vor zwei Jahren eine Knie-Atroskopie
und dabei eine Meniscus-Operation.
Was genau gemacht wurde, wissen wir nicht.
Die Familie in Anamnese zeigt beim 52-jährigen Kratz
zilivierende Ulzeradu Denehy, eine arterielle Hypertonie
und vor zwei Jahren eine Myocarditis.
Wahrscheinlich im Zusammenhang mit einer Covid-Neuerankung.
Die 59-jährige Mutter leidet ebenfalls an einem Asthma-Brontiale.
Die 24-jährige Schwester ist gesund.
Ja, das sind so die wesentlichen Schatten.
Der Patient treibt sonst sportregelmäßig,
aber das kann er in den letzten Wochen
aufgrund seiner Erschöpfung und Leistungsminderung nicht.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Aufgrund der anamnischen Angaben
gehe ich von einem Verdacht auf, Tyroiditis aus.
Und als Differenzialdiagnose kommt
Larangitis, Asthma-Brontiale A-Tage
und Hypoteroid in Betrag.
Okay.
Was würden Sie bei einer Tyroiditis denn erwarten?
Ist die Schildrüse da schmerzhaft?
Druckschmerzhaft?
Ja, Druck.
Der Patient hat ja keine Schmerzen.
Er sagt nur, er hat ein Schwellungsgefühl
und er zeigt seitlich so mehr.
Das ja.
Da ist es geschwollen.
Und dann hat er eben auch dieses Druckgefühl im linken Oberbauch.
Ja.
Und er hat eine Gewichtsabnahme von acht Kilogramm
innerhalb von zwei Monaten.
Und er war in Thailand.
Ja.
Mononucleosis.
Epstein-Bar.
Epstein-Bar?
Ja.
Okay.
Wie würden Sie denn bei der Mononucleosis
hätten wir eventuell auch ein Druckgefühl im linken Oberbauch?
Was könnte das sein, das Druckgefühl im linken Oberbauch?
Leber.
Was liegt da noch für ein Organ im linken Oberbauch?
Ziemlich versteckt.
Linken Oberbauch.
Ja.
Mies.
Das ist schon geschrieben, eine Splenomegalin.
Ja.
Da muss man daran denken.
Das kann bei der Mononucleose auch sein,
eine Splenomegalin.
Aber der Patient, glaube ich, hat eine klassische B-Symptomatik.
Ja.
Er hat eine Gewichtsabnahme.
Nachtschweiß.
Wahrscheinlich eine Splenomegalin.
Er hat servikale Schwellungen,
die er noch nicht richtig einsortieren kann.
Die Gewichtsabnahme, das würde ich sagen,
spricht eher für eine B-Symptomatik im Sinne,
eventuell vielleicht eines Lymphom, was der Patient hat.
Differenzialdiagnostisch würde ich an eine Malaria denken.
Ja.
Weil natürlich der Patient in Malaria-Gebiet war.
Er hat eine Profilachse betrieben,
aber wir wissen, eine Profilachse ist nicht
100-prozentig.
Aber auch eine Mononucleose, finde ich, kommt im Betracht.
Thürioiditis würde ich nicht sagen.
Weil die tut in Allgemeinen, tut das weh, hat der Schmerzen.
Und ich glaube, da wäre der Patient eher zum Arzt gegangen.
Weil ich glaube, das ist teilweise sehr schmerzhaft.
Ja.
Und da ist das Schlucken eingeschränkt.
Und insgesamt, also die Thürioiditis würde ich eher
in der Differenzialdiagnostik an fünfte, sechste Stelle stellen.
Verdacht auf B-Symptomatik,
verdacht auch vielleicht auf eine Systemerkrankung, leider.
Ja, Systemerkrankung.
DD, Malaria, Mononucleose, das kommt alles sicherlich auch mit im Betracht.
Ein Kollege hatte ja gefragt mit der Rohmilch.
Herr Kollege, meinten Sie Brutzelose?
Hört das nicht zu, ne?
Ein Kollege fragte, ob der Patient schon mal Käse aus Rohmilch gegessen hat,
glaube ich.
Mein, damit Brutzelose?
Ja, ich glaube, ein Kollege meint Brutzelose.
Und er fragt, ob sie, ob...
Rohmilch.
Genau, genau.
Er dachte, da war es wahrscheinlich ein Brutzelose, ne?
Ist sicherlich in Deutschland, kommt es auch, glaube ich, immer wieder vor.
Es wird ja immer wieder berichtet.
Viel seltener, glaube ich, als, jetzt sage ich mal, im Mittelmeerraum,
in warmen Klimazonen auch.
Hier ist die Brutzelose noch nicht so gut in den Köpfen der Ärzte.
Ja?
Ich habe davon gehört, aber ich habe noch nie einen Patienten
mit einer Brutzelose gehabt, muss ich Ihnen ehrlich sagen.
Vielleicht habe ich auch zu wenig dran gedacht.
Das ist ja immer das Problem.
Gut, aber ich finde, Sie haben das trotzdem sehr gut gemacht,
auch wenn ich Sie jetzt häufig unterbrochen habe.
Aber das tut der Oberarzt in der Prüfung wahrscheinlich immer mal wieder,
dass der Oberarzt nachfragt oder der Oberarzt ist ungeduldig,
er hat keine Zeit, er möchte möglichst entscheidende Informationen
innerhalb kurzer Zeit haben.
Ja?
Ich würde die Forschung, aber ich weiß, dass es Unterschiede gibt.
Ich würde die Vorstellung vielleicht in der Richtung
ein bisschen anders machen.
Ich würde in vorderen Stellen der Patient leidet aktuell
unter diesen Beschwerden.
Und dann würde ich wahrscheinlich gleich in dem Zusammenhang
schon sagen, auffällig ist eine Gewichtsabnahme von 8 kg
innerhalb von zwei Monaten.
Weil das gehört eigentlich in diese aktuelle Beschwerdesymptomatik rein.
Und bei Ihrem Aufbau der Anamnese kommen Sie erst ziemlich weit am Ende
mit der vegetativen Anamnese, nach der familienanamnese und so weiter,
glaube ich.
Und das ist in diesem Zusammenhang, würde ich sagen, ist das relativ spät.
Aber das muss jeder für sich entscheiden.
Hauptsache, Sie vergessen das nicht.
Ja?
Weil das sind schon diese sogenannten Red Flags in der Anamnese
bei den Patienten.
Er hat Fieber.
Er hat eine Gewichtsabnahme, die ist massiv, die ist sehr stark.
Und er hat diese Schwellungszustände, die er nicht einsortieren kann.
Und er hat diese ausgesprochenen Leistungsknick,
dass er sich nicht mehr in der Lage fühlt,
aus seinen geliebten Sport zu machen.
Das sind so Red Flags, wo man dann denken müsste,
wahrscheinlich und leider hat dieser Patient
vielleicht eine Systemerkrankung.
Ja.
Gut.
Aber trotzdem finde ich, haben Sie das gut gemacht
und das hat mir gut gefallen.
Verwechseln Sie, es ist Herr Habeck, sagen Sie bitte eher
und nicht Sie, verwechseln Sie da nicht das Geschlecht,
in dem Sinne, das passiert immer wieder.
Da achten Sie bitte darauf.
Wann haben Sie Ihre Prüfung?
Meint.
Und wann?
Meine Prüfung, 4. Februar.
Ja, gut.
Das ist ja bald.
Und ich habe ein gutes Gefühl, dass Sie die Prüfung gut machen.
Bewahren Sie die Ruhe und Gelassenheit
und dann werden Sie das gut hinkriegen.
Vielen Dank.
Ich wünsche Ihnen alles Gute.